is in fact with us right now Fabiano
congratulations welcome back to the show
it felt like there's no difference
between you two guys after 40th move and
all the way into the end game how did
you create that separation when did you
know that you finally achieved that
separation yeah it was it was rather
silly because I played the opening in a
terrible way as I as I often do in this
Italian I don't know why I keep playing
it but I got a slightly worse
position uh like just slightly worse and
it kind of reminded me a bit of the game
we played last year where I was slightly
worse for most most of it and then when
he gets into time trouble he makes some
rather questionable decisions like I
thought Rook e 7 was a very strange
decision because I'm slightly worse and
also I can't do anything and then he um
well he allows me a pretty like
risk-free position I don't I didn't feel
like I was any more in danger play this
point yeah yeah very like queen7 or
something
yeah he just changed the structure with
no time which I understand he wanted to
release attention because okay it's a
tense position and we he had 3 seconds
but it's clear black is maybe slightly
better maybe much better but certainly
not worse and after Rook E7 I'm
definitely not worse anymore y um that's
what I felt and I started to play more
or less for win because I have I have
more time and and I didn't feel like I
was worse then of course there was a
dead draw uh and he made the time
control with this last move G5 Knight D2
h 4 and Knight takes E4 how did you see
your chances of uh winning this game at
this
point like
1% like the position it's the problem is
that his Knight is so good that I can't
really create threats and not only that
my king is also vulnerable so I thought
the position is a dead draw and uh I
didn't even feel like white can really
play this position like it felt if
someone's playing for a win it's it's
just as much black as white like neither
side can really play for a win I thought
if he wants to force a draw the easiest
was before King E8 yes uh Knight D4 is
just okay I was that's what we were
expecting as well yeah yeah I mean here
I I can't uh I I have to take and the
point is these Queen ands can sometimes
be trick okay this is just immediate
Perpetual they can sometimes be tricky
tricky if his Queen is is on for example
D7 but on on H5 he can go to G4 if he
wants he can go to h8 if he wants so I
kind of have to take on D4 um
and then he played King E8 and I was
actually for like five minutes I was
thinking okay I'll play Queen D5 and
make a draw and then suddenly I like saw
Bishop F6 is uh is still risk free oh
sorry King G Bishop
F6 is is kind of risk- free and it's a
little bit tricky for him because first
I thought okay Knight D4 should be a
dead draw but then I thought Bishop D4
Queen
D7 King F2 well CD4 also King F2 Queen
D7 King F2 so I think Queen D yes if CD4
then then King F2 as well uh and here
okay Queen D4 I get a a winning Pawn end
game and if CD4 I play this at least SI
to much win I mean um and CD4 I play E5
and it's like a little bit unpleasant he
got into time trouble and he didn't want
to play his position MH like I play
Queen E4 Queen D5 I get my queen in the
king kind of blocks the D Pawn it's
risk- free I mean okay probably a draw
there's something to play for right yeah
there's something to play for suddenly
and then I thought his last moment when
like I thought his idea so it was
interesting when he played this queen H5
move this is when I actually had um some
hope because if he wants to play Queen
H3 then it forces Queen A8 Knight f8 and
I had realized that this position is
like Queen H3 here for
example instead of Queen H5 Queen A8 he
has to play Knight f8 to avoid losing
Queen and Bishop B7 Queen H2 uh is a
draw mhm que King F3 MH Queen H1 it's
very important he goes to H1 mhm uh King
G4 and queen
D1 MH maybe oh wait maybe F5 is is
dangerous but but in any case like he
doesn't risk because my Bishop on E7 is
loose so my king doesn't really have
anywhere to go right so when he played
Queen H5 I realized that he wanted the
only reason to put the queen on this
square is to play King G6 so you don't
lose the queen and I I started to feel
some hope in this end game because it's
very very tricky I don't know I guess
it's a draw but it's a very tricky draw
after Bishop B5 I mean with no time like
you know white doesn't risk he play to
go into this he played it well and I
think it was this moment when um he
played the move G4 which gave you some
clear chances King to G4 seems to have
been the better move but again with only
a few seconds on the clock the clock
winding down the problem is this this is
not easy this is a race right like I
play Bishop C7 and then I bring my king
he takes G3 I I mean uh King D3 yeah
like okay G4 I I guess the race is fine
for him but yeah yeah King C3 Knight D4
Bishop A5 King G3 Bishop B6 like he
white doesn't risk right yeah um Knight
E6 yeah Knight E6 probably probably he
missed this move which is is important
and then he's in time yeah so okay yeah
it's it's drawing margin is high but uh
it's it's easy to miss these type of
moves of
course or misal
um yeah this is kind of how how it
starts to to to sort of snowball when
you it's a draw it's a draw and then
suddenly you have to like make one
difficult decision and then suddenly
it's uh it's not a draw anymore and we
call this uh final moment when you
played this move I believe it was
somewhere around I'm trying to find it
Bishop H6 you play this move Bishop to
H6 at this point and we call this dark
magic because it's in fact I believe the
only move that wins this position you
found it very quickly how did you do
that yeah I kind of saw it in advance I
I realized that once my Bishop is on C3
it's just his Knight is cut and he no
longer has any checks like his his
checks don't lead anywhere so Bishop on
C on C3 is ideal then my king goes to E4
and he doesn't have any um anything like
he's both tied to the pawn and his King
also gets cut off and like after King E4
there's no longer Knight D2 which was
kind of what was saving him with the
bishop on C7 right he had this Knight D2
check yeah so I just wanted to get my
Bishop there I and
okay I kind of quickly saw that this
route is uh is the way to do it and King
F6 then then the King goes to E4 right
so um oh sorry King F6 King C3 yeah so
it's it's
um not no wait wait no sorry no no king6
Bishop to no King E4 is fine oh yeah
King E4 okay I I even forgot what my
intention was but I guess I guess King
E4 was my intention yeah um yeah once
the king is on e4 then he gets like
Bishop on E3 and then he gets cut his
King gets cut off so yeah it was a tough
game what can I say tough game but very
good result for your campaign and your
chances to defend the title
congratulations as you go into the rest
day Katherina do you have any
questions um didn't have any question
but let's ask some now you are a Soul
Leader Fabby you probably did not expect
it uh yesterday to be so leader after
today how do you feel
yeah of course excellent I mean things
couldn't have possibly gone better like
I really shouldn't have made two points
from the last two games I mean uh one
point would have been normal from the
positions uh maybe maybe one and a half
uh but uh but two is definitely really
uh unexpectedly good and um yeah it's
it's a bit up and down for everyone else
I mean obviously uh there's a there's a
a lot of people who are close and it's
just start getting started so it's not
like um not like I'm you know getting
getting ahead of myself yet but it's
it's of course very good to win this
game absolutely fabul happy to be your
wingman on this ending uh amazing
determination there was just one brief
moment at the very very very end King F
and it was this moment that caused us a
little bit of Mirth but did you see the
move Knight
D2 at the
veryan just had to ask oh my God
is this still winning it's still win yes
it's still winning it's still winning I
I assure you but it was a it was a nice
moment it was a very funny Mo
moment no but this is like almost
spoiling it yeah I have to play Bishop
A5 Knight G3 King E5 right Bishop A5
Knight C4 Bishop C7 Bishop C7 oh wait
what am I I I'm hallucinating I thought
okay never you are winning you are
winning but night2 fun at the moment I
I'm really hallucinating everything I
for a second I thought the night on D
could take could take G3 I thought this
was like a super KN I was getting really
worried like this KN Knight takes G3
check is also a threat and right no at
the at the moment I'm I'm I'm kind of uh
hallucinating things so so let's not
talk about Chess anymore go get your
rest uh congratulations and we'll see
you on
Tuesday thank you absolutely night D2
that would have been fun